hey guys I'm Jessa McDonald it's the
tenth of every and you're joining me for
another week of games what news let's do
monday initially it looked like watchdog
on wii u had been cancelled but now we
found out that it's just going to be
launching later than the other version
unlike nintendo struggling platform the
ps3 ps4 xbox one xbox 360 and pc will
have their versions land at launch
between april and june of 2014 as
confirmed by you soft now i do like to
try and keep compiling the crap on when
nintendo was already doing it tough but
i think it's still worth highlighting a
white 33 comment on gamespot who said
that sucks the nintendo and its fan
please put down your pitch box it's just
a joke let me know if you're a Nintendo
fan and if you'd want to play watchdogs
on Wii U next up the Grand saga of
flappy bird grabbed weekend news by the
talons and made everything else seem
pretty insignificant a very simple
torture chamber appropriate mobile game
has brought many a game of to tears and
thrown smashing but it seems that that
may be extending to the creator himself
it's hard to say why don't you and has
received so much flak for his game
flappy bird but one suspects it may be
due to the amount of abuse he's received
some fans you can't get that Jam bird
through the freaking hole in the pipe
seriously all we know is that it's not a
legal issue or at least that's what you
and confirms through Twitter that
particular issue wouldn't be that far
fetched since the game is based on a
number of other games that share
mechanics and artwork from which flappy
bird has borrowed liberally that's all
coming to an end now though since the
Creator said the game will be coming
down and to please not ask why is this
all super ominous or do you think you
figured out what's going on here let me
know laughs up there's finally a theory
on why the ps4 is running more games
1080p then the xbox one snypa 30 dev
john baptiste will qatar has told
gamingbolt that the problem is that the
xbox one's embedded SRAM is too small to
output 1080p despite that he does point
out that the development on the Xbox one
has improved over the last six months
and in his opinion while the ps4 is a
bit more powerful on paper at the moment
the xbox one is going to catch up what
do you guys think about the performance
differences and do you agree that the
xbox one will close the gap you can let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below or on my Twitter where I'm at
just McDonald that's it for me but i'll
be updating you on all the most
interesting gaming things as they are
all this week our piece